the mob is already coming after after
this police officer
the mob being led by the zillionaire
athlete idiot lebron james
who tweeted out his picture and said all
caps
you're next with a with a an hourglass
and it says accountability
accountability is the new word that the
left is using instead of justice
because what the left is calling for is
not justice because justice is an
objective eternal thing
that we perceive and try to
pursue in our lives accountability is
totally a social fact accountability is
just responsiveness responsibility it's
just
it's just what i demand from you well
that then you are accountable to me
but it's not based on anything objective
or eternal
i actually think that's the distinction
at the heart here between accountability
and justice she's saying yeah we're
coming for you cop
hero cop who did the right thing and
saved a life we're coming for you
lebron james deleted that tweet that's
good
glad he recognized he was wrong but then
he sent out this tweet afterward and he
just talked about you know it's the
being used for bad things might in the
racism but i'm sick
of it it's awful it's terrible nobody no
no you don't get it you don't get it
lebron you don't get that it was
absolutely right and just for that cop
to shoot mikaya bryant
i don't think he could have behaved any
more appropriately
because he it's not like he she runs out
of the house and he just starts shooting
he waited until the knife was inches
from the other girl
and then he shot her that's a good you
should lebron james not when you
apologize when you take that tweet down
not only should you apologize for that
tweet you should thank that cop for
doing his job
and for pursuing justice and you should
say i lebron james
a total dummy was wrong
i i leapt to a conclusion that was not
right
thank you sir for pursuing justice you
think that's going to happen i don't
think so
because lebron is a victim don't you
know
lebron james can't leave his house
without being hunted down by
racist white people is that so
lebron he's he is this poor aggrieved
man
who lives in a world of white privilege
i do not want to be lectured by lebron
james
on privilege i you almost can't blame
lebron here
for the same reason that you feel bad
for criminals
you also feel bad for totally benighted
ignorant idiots like lebron james
because i think he genuinely believes
this stuff
flies in the face of objective reality
flies in the face of everything we see
i think lebron james really does believe
that he's a victim that he has
legitimate
grievance that this country a black man
can't make it in this country
lebron he thinks this from his i imagine
golden palace that he's from his throne
that he's sitting on in a zillion dollar
house
one of the most beloved for whatever
reason and
wealthy and famous people in the country
can't make it though because of the
color of his skin right
he believe and the i'm not i'm not being
facetious when i say i sort of feel bad
for his deep ignorance
he has been raised in a culture
that increasingly teaches people this
sort of thing
wait a second way down not so fast pull
your hands away from the keyboard or
from your screen
you've got to smash that button you got
to
subscribe you got to like you've got to
make sure that you
get all of the videos that are coming up
because youtube
doesn't necessarily love our content
they don't always want to promote it so
make sure
that you are there for all the latest
videos see you next time